i ragazzi benvenuti a questo video sono
parecchio ci siamo dati su siamo sul
centosessantesimo episodio cosa vuol
dire siamo arrivati ad episodio special
gioco questa parte di livelli che sta su
play il non sul blog che bruce labruce
che sarebbero i livelli di giocatori
questi sono sempre i miei giocatori ma i
top del mondo l'ultima volta ne avevo
fatti un botto arriviamo a piramide of
the gods sicuramente cliccherà un
livello che ho già fatto però la peste o
di non farlo bellissimo lo fermi per già
allora la copertina del video cielo poi
magari non sarà questa perché sono
livelli talmente incredibili ma
proviamoci ragazzi allora poi la
piramide degli dei le scop salve
iniziamo subito schiacciando un serpente
poverino ha fatto niente ma mi sa che mi
sa che la passione da schiaccia ma sto
meno più lontano i serpenti invece a
posto allora ragazzi e ogni volta che mi
scusi
ogni volta che faccio livelli migliori
al mondo di happy days mi prendo bene
perché sono fatti decisamente meglio
degli ornamenti di una normale però alle
volte mi sorprendono veramente troppi in
positivo questo è uno dei più giocati in
assoluto adesso visto tipo centro aiuto
era horus quello
non ho ben capito cosa è successo
proprio va bene fate signora è una boss
fight da mi ha colpito di nuovo papà mi
sa che colpisce più forte lui però
allora sì o servente via molto bene
quindi devo colpire la gente da colpire
gli dei che non avevo ancora fatto
va bene la goulue che sei lì che tanto
non serve una sega nella sua vita prima
vedere se sta facendo a muro e quindi
devo semplicemente toccarlo ogni volta
che un casino pan 28 che poi arriva il
coso non mi ricordo prima dove due sono
stato schiacciato prova per niente aiuto
meno male che non sono andato veloce
perfetto 2
mammamia rischiamo sacco adesso prova a
lasciarla non so se riescono ci provo
poi ho fatto ma torno non ci credo ma
come come sono morto
mi piace perché sono i melli competitivi
c'e nel senso in genere livelli fanno
cagare cioè poi li fai subito o muori
subito quindi non c'è una via di mezzo
questo quadro non certo livello
ed è proprio difficile magari per
quest'episodio faccio sono questo
livello perché non riuscirò a finirlo
subito però cioè ci sta a fare anche
solo questo spero di riuscire a finirlo
per l'amor di dio solo livello in un
video farebbe strano però ci potrebbe
stare per quanto è fatto bene l'attore
non so neanche come faccio a farli marea
squadra che lo sto semplicemente
investendo con la rotazione che sia il
massimo tutto bene luke vai tranquillo
occhio occhio occhio come ha fatto prima
essere schiacciato non ho capito ho
trovato mio figlio a parte mio figlio ho
trovato una chiave let's go tutto sto
casino per trovare una chiave grazia uk
josean dimenticati
vado al ros andiamo andiamo di qua c'è
un altro serpente
mi scusi infor e c'è il centro
informazioni invece anche ovviamente il
banco informazioni dentro le piramidi
egiziane avevano pensato a tutto allora
click on the icon bottene information ok
horus il dio del cielo
il dio più facile da battere su con solo
quattro colpi osiris e il più difficile
ok va bene allora andiamo a vedere il
tedesco a battere osiris il primo lo fa
ogni volta devo iniziare da zero ragazzi
che li veramente difficile
c'è questo è un livello incredibile per
finirlo ci metti una vita
devi battere tutti gli dei isis non
sapevo che easy se fosse un dio mio dio
porca vacca che terroristi intanto la
sta ancora colpendo attenzione
vai vinci vai bici colpisce sto battendo
isis senza fare niente perché dagli
amici la colpisce guarda i miei pezzi di
carne la colpiscono vai combatti alle
ragazze subito horus ma ne sono uscito
con una ruota in meno quindi non so
quanto effettivamente sia ragionevole
andare avanti ma proviamoci che parola
batte dell'isis senza la ruota la mano
allora proviamo a dare senso perfetto
allora un colpo c'è l'app basta che ski
mira ad inutili teoricamente non devi
costruire e non è così facile parco de
la7 che veramente di genova
penso sia a livello più difficile che
abbia mai fatto
tolti gli imposti come perché quali sono
una categoria a parte ma veramente
difficile ragazzi quindi visto veramente
impegnandolo non è non è per niente
facile io ci gioco da una vita e prima
ancora che fu creato ragazzi siamo
tornati da isis non so cosa devo fare
per vincere ma veramente visto
ammazzando per riuscirci ok sonorità di
nuovo bravo hanno colpito sono veramente
forte comunque devono denotare questa
cosa grazie isis che tieni la mia faccia
allora guarda
ok allora se riesco a sono le spine a
posto tutto bene tutto bene tutto a
posto due colpi da due volte record
zucco demonio veramente difficile
ragazzi devo pregare
ho sbagliato sono vivo madonna la
primavera vinta capito c'è un casino nel
proprio di ditta madonna ragazzo
incredibile c'è chi giura è
difficilissimo e coupé la vita e il pci
farla fuori è veramente un raga
l'impegno questo vale ad essere il video
piuttosto faccio il libro piuttosto in
un video faccio solo un livello ma lo
devo finire giuro e veramente
incredibile devo finirlo è strano perché
oggi e apri giornata speciale dei
livelli incredibili che in genere faccio
due o tre per che durano un sacco e se
uno non mi è mai successo se solo ci
fosse stato uno shock e ragazzi miei
sarebbe già finito sto video perché
l'imbattibile però noto con dispiacere
che il padre di uk e non è così forte
madonna che botta dai prof
gli ho tirato una bozza talmente forte e
doveva morire subito pro mamma mia oh
allora madonna devi morire
basta poi andò mika salo va dai raggi
miss capisce bene il sesto nel mezzo
dello stare qua davanti nel mezzo nel
mezzo del mezzo nel mezzo
nel mezzo non davanti madonna poi ci
credo che uno dei livelli più giocatori
grazie cioè impossibile vincere non li
fai un milione di volte dei vai 2 e poi
muoiono così ma dai ma dai l'avevo
colpita quasi recuperato tutta la vita o
sono la colpisci maschile più rincorsa e
non posso andarci ci stanno di razza
bilico che madonna avrebbe imposto no
ragazzi incredibile cioè io vi giuro non
so cosa fare è troppo difficile
maida regolarità basta a noi
che fastidio non è che più rincorsa
prende più danno le faccio ma non era
molto chiara ma tanto agli se ne frega
sono morto allora adesso durante gli
faccio vedere adesso durante la boxe
fight non questa la prima va beh durante
la vos fight sto zitto
giuro sto zitto perché mi concentro ti
giuro non la concentrazione faccio
proprio questo non è più il suo giocando
a dark souls quindi mi concentro
veramente subito molto difficile però mi
concentravo proprio come se fosse un
gioco
normale perché non è un giorno normale e
non dico niente ragazzi proviamoci ci
siamo ragazzi 31 via
[Musica]
togliti figlio stupido dai
[ __ ]
no io mi sono veramente impegnato
tantissimo poi uk dove andate a finire
lo so solo lui però mi sono veramente
impregnanti ragazzi io sto coprendo un
sacco di volte più di così non so che
fare ok va bene va bene
a occhio aiuto dai arrivare un tombino
madonna questo schivato adesso se ce
l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta ciabatta fermi
e zitti signori chiave d'oro ma don due
ore prende veramente ci ho messo
tantissimo ragazzi non è solamente un
sacco c'è solo per fare il suo livello
siamo a 23 minuti di video certo
registrando un sacco per fare sta roba
veramente
forse devo tornare 18 può essere dietro
c'era un coso che non ho visto anche
eccoci siamo al boss finale chi è is
here is easy ma qual è la seconda
attenzione osiris colpito non puoi nulla
contro di me
ragazzi se vogliono rifare tutti i ragni
cioè certo spider hanno anche dei nomi
spider joe e spider bob uno è morto
spider giovini quando spyer boss ucciso
spider bop che di qua e mori io che male
questa cosa devo fare qua sono fasi
aiuto colpito possono fare solo cliccare
1 colpisco e non si fa niente aiuto
contro series bravissimo manca ancora
una fase ci stanno a nubi qua eccolo
addio al nubilato colpisci cosa faccio
lo colpisce barca va a casa cosa è
bruttissima e colpisci e si mai più
lento ma devo trigger anni l'attacco
cosa devo fare
madonna gaza colpisci no ti prego come
pete ha ucciso guardate veramente
pazzesco mi arrendo adelphi wheels mi
arrendo veramente difficile complimenti
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
siete un con me non so datemi un
consiglio veramente impossibile rai come
sempre ci riferiamo ad un prossimo video
dei ragazzi questo mi ha bisogno
preferito di happy meals
[Musica]